So, da sind wir wieder.
Ich musste den Server wechseln, auf den ich streame.
Jetzt sollte es wieder alles funktionieren.
Wo davon ist auch richtiger Schrott?
So, wo sind wir gerade stehen geblieben?
Ich habe mich gerade aufgeregt über Helpline, korrekt?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Leute?
Ich glaube, Helpline.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, du kennst das.
Du kennst das.
Wenn du das kennst, wirst du wahrscheinlich auch wissen, wie kacke Helpline ist.
Und ganz ehrlich, Leute, guckt euch dieses Ding an.
Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welches.
Grausam, grausam, grausam, ja.
Und ohne Scheiß, Leute, Helpline ist das räudigste Ticketsystem.
Und das schlechteste und nervigste Ticketsystem, was ich jemals gesehen habe.
Richtiger, richtiger Schrott, Sgt. Silver.
Richtiger Schrott.
Sag mal, ich habe mal eine Frage, Sgt. Silver.
Haben wir mal Battlefield gegeneinander gespielt?
Oder zusammen, oder so?
Nein?
Moment.
Ich hatte doch mal irgendeinen Clip hochgeladen, bei mir auf dem damals Zweit-Zweit-Channel,
wo ich manchmal Battlefield-Zeug hochgeladen habe, vor acht Jahren.
Und jetzt weiß ich nicht, wo.
Da hieß doch auch einer irgendwie Sgt. Silver oder sowas.
Ja, gut.
Wie das Video einfach 214.000 Aufruf hat.
Gut, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich bin ja wieder etwas sidetracked worden.
Helpline Classic, ja, so hieß das.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, so hieß das.
Ich glaube, so hieß das.
Ah, ja, ja, perfekt.
Ja, ja, das ist es.
Das ist es.
Was ist denn das für ein Kack?
Monkeys.
Es ist immer noch ein Kack-PDF, Mann.
Das ist es.
Das ist das Ticketsystem, Leute.
Das ist so ätzend.
Das ist so dermaßen schrottig, Alter.
Ja.
Gucken wir mal in das PDF rein hier.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Chrome...
Kannst du ja auch.
Guckt euch das an.
Windows.
Windows only.
Du musst das administrieren.
Okay, nice.
Das ist so schrottig, Alter.
Das ist ohne Scheiß das ätzendste und schlimmste Ticketsystem, mit dem ich jemals machen musste.
Guckt euch...
Ich meine, guckt euch allein schon mal die Oberfläche an, da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, oder?
Wenn ich das schon sehe.
Naja, gut.
Ja, nice.
Willst du sagen, dass Parkside schrott ist?
Parkside ist Lidl.
Parkside ist, wenn man sich Refuse anguckt, gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich habe gesündigt.
Sowieso, was hast du gemacht?
Zu viel Buber.
Was, was?
Was hast du getrieben?
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn das 40 Jahre überlebt hat, dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut Qualität.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich Arch use, by the way, aber dabei benutze ich Manjaro.
Chat.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Icos benutzt Manjaro und dann sagt, dass er Arch benutzt.
Also, das können wir nicht durchgehen lassen.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, wie da ein geeignetes Punishment für aussieht.
Ich würde sagen...
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht irgendwas in C++ programmieren, oder so.
Wie kann ich das wieder gut machen?
Ja, ich überlege mir noch was.
Ich überlege mir noch was.
Vielleicht eine Präsentation über C++23 Features.
Oder eine Woche mit der Bahn fahren, ja.
Weiß ich gar nicht, was da mehr...
Wobei, Bahn fahren, wenn sie fährt, ja gar kein Problem ist.
Zamat kenne ich nicht.
Sound-Ticket-System.
Zamat.
Helpdesk.
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert, wie viele es von diesen Systemen gibt.
Was ist eigentlich...
Das ist Jira.
Was ist eigentlich die Daseinsberechtigung von 500 verschiedenen Ticket-Systemen,
Helpdesk-Systemen, Knowledge-Based-Systemen?
Ich würde sagen, ganz ehrlich, warum kann man nicht einfach Jira und Doku-Wiki oder sowas verwenden?
Hast du schon mal Semaphore benutzt?
Ja.
Also falls es ein Ticket-System gibt, was so heißt, nein, dann nicht.
Wenn du ein Proggers-Stellstil geht, dann schon.
Weil Jira Schrott ist?
Echt?
Warum?
Also ich muss sagen, eigentlich bin ich bisher Jira mit das angenehmste Ticket-System.
Das kann ja keine E-Mails richtig darstellen, was...
Jo...
Okay.
Dann...
Dann verstehe ich...
Ja.
Dann hast du andere Anforderungen an das Ticket-System, als ich.
Das...
Das hatte ich...
Das hatte ich noch nicht.
Ich überlege gerade, was wir damals beim Provider führten.
Für ein Ticket-System haben.
Hatten.
Wie gibt es...
Also, weder haben, weil ich nicht mehr dabei bin, noch haben, weil den Laden gibt es nicht mehr.
Der ist pleite.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Es war nicht Jira.
Das ist viel zu lang, viel zu alt.
Da gab es noch kein Jira.
Das war 2007.
2007 bis 2011 oder so war ich da.
Aber...
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie das Ticket-System hieß.
Aus Doku und To-Do-Liste, zum Beispiel.
Ach so, wie wäre es mit Doku-Wiki, wenn einfach sonst nichts geht?
Und das Schöne an Doku-Wiki ist auch noch, dass es Plain-Text ist.
Wie gesagt, ich finde Jira gar nicht so übel.
Also, wenn man es nicht komplett misshandelt mit irgendwelchen komischen Plugins, dass nichts mehr übrig ist vom ursprünglichen Ding.
Ich finde Jira auch noch die Box ist echt okay.
Wenn man das halt für Soft...
Als Ticket-System für Software-Entwicklung zum Beispiel verwendet.
Ja, wenn man es zweckentfremdet, ist jedes System und jedes Tool gut.
Ja, wenn man es zweckentfremdet, ist jedes System und jedes Tool kacke.
Okay, das klingt nicht so geil.
Ja.
Wir haben gestern C++ gemacht, Advent of Code.
Allerdings habe ich Rage quittet, weil ich die Sprache nicht mehr ertragen habe.
Object Storage...
Okay, was willst du machen genau?
Weil...
Die haben ja einige...
Die haben ja einige Features nachgerüstet in den letzten Versionen.
Die haben ja mittlerweile auch beispielsweise eine Container Registry usw.
dabei.
Was ich sehr nice finde, ehrlich gesagt.
NWU allein habe ich noch nicht benutzt.
Oh, Sadge.
FeelsBadMan.
Ja, da hast du wahrscheinlich Glück.
Da ist nicht so viel passiert.
Remedy habe ich auch schon mal gehört.
Aber das hatten wir beim Provider nicht.
Das war...
Vielleicht war das sogar irgendwas Selbstgestricktes.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Bookstack basiert nicht auf Plaintext, sondern auf einer Datenbank.
Deswegen mag ich das nicht so.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich läuft das da auch seit 2008.
Ja, hast schon recht.
Hast schon recht.
Ich würde zwischen...
Ich hätte da jetzt gar keinen Unterschied dazwischen gemacht.
Aber es ist eindeutig darauf ausgelegt.
Ja, das merkt man auch schon an den ganzen Presets.
Also, dass das vielleicht jetzt bei einer Hotline zum Beispiel nicht gut passt als Problem-Tracking-Geschichte und sowas.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Übrigens, das ist ja was ich gesehen habe.
Das müssen wir auch nochmal demnächst sehen.
Das müssen wir auch nochmal im Stream ausprobieren.
Der Typ, der Uptime-Kuma programmiert hat, das ist...
Das will ich euch gar nicht zeigen eigentlich, aber ich sag mal so, für Leute, die es nicht kennen und daheim vielleicht irgendwie auf dem Raspberry Pi oder auf dem kleinen x86-Server bei sich daheim Anwendung betreiben und überwachen wollen, ob die Systeme up oder down sind, ist das tatsächlich mit die simpelste Monitoring-Software, die es gibt für den Heimbereich.
Das ist eigentlich auch super easy zu benutzen.
Natürlich nicht die großen Features, wie beispielsweise jetzt Zabbix oder was mit Prometheus selbst gestrickt ist oder Nagios oder CheckMK und was habe ich noch vergessen?
Es gibt ja tausende Monitoring-Sachen.
Ichinga und Sensu und was auch immer.
Zumindest, wenn man einfach nur wissen will, Seite up, down, Server pink, nicht pink, ist das net...
Ja, aber da wollte ich gar nicht drauf aus.
Ich habe gesehen, dass der Luis, der Luis hat irgendwie ein neues Projekt am Start.
Genau, Dockke.
Das könnte ohne Scheiß irgendein...
Das klingt wie ein Twitch-E-Mode, oder?
Dockke.
Das ist ein fancy, easy-to-use, reactive, self-hosted, docker-composed, stack-oriented Manager.
Klingt super kompliziert.
Letztendlich ist es ein Web-Interface, wo man...
...Docker-composed-Dateien anlegen kann.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es sowas wie Portena ist.
Zumindest nicht in dem Umfang.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Ich meine, ich habe keinen wirklichen Anwendungszweck dafür, ehrlich gesagt.
Also im Enterprise-Umfeld eh nicht.
Und selbst daheim auch nicht.
Aber ich finde es immer ganz gut, drüber auf dem Laufenden zu sein.
Was denn so...
...an Entwicklungen gibt.
Ich sage doch, Dock geklingt...
Also bei mir würde es Docker-Champ heißen.
Oder Dock-Champ.
Oder sowas.
Oder Container-Champ.
Proxmox haben wir uns sogar schon im Stream angeschaut.
Ist für meinen Einsatzzweck nicht so das Wahre.
Ich will halt was haben.
Für Storage.
Für Docker-Container.
Und für VMs. Alles in einem.
Ich bin aktuell bei Unraid gelandet.
So hundertprozentig glücklich bin ich auch nicht.
Wenn mein hauptsächlicher Einsatz...
...Einsatzzweck Virtualisierung wäre.
Beziehungsweise Container, die ich selbst mit irgendeinem Compose-File oder gar einem Kubernetes oder sowas.
Dann vielleicht.
Aber aktuell nicht.
Was für Probleme hast du mit Unraid?
Gar keine.
Man kann nicht wirklich sagen Probleme.
So insgesamt bin ich einfach nicht so richtig glücklich damit.
Ja.
Das Web-Interface wirkt ein bisschen wie vor 10 Jahren entwickelt.
Und wenn es auch ein paar moderne Ansätze hat, wirkt das teilweise doch schon ziemlich altbacken.
Manches braucht sehr lang bis es gefixt ist.
Die haben gefühlt ein halbes Jahr gebraucht, bis sie das gepatcht haben, dass die Verbindung zu Dockerhub wieder richtig funktioniert.
Dass die Container nicht dastehen, als hätte jemand sein Dockerhub-Repo gelöscht.
Haben die irgendwie fast ein halbes Jahr für gebraucht, das zu fixen.
Manchmal ein bisschen langsam.
Aber ich fände es auch ein bisschen blöd, dass es auf Slackware basiert, ehrlich gesagt.
Andere Sachen wären deutlich angenehmer, da was dran zu drehen noch.
Ja.
Aber insgesamt ist es schon...
Ja, TrueNAS habe ich mir angesehen, hat mir gar nicht gefallen.
Ich glaube, TrueNAS, wenn ich das richtig zusammenkriege, Initialeindruck von TrueNAS war eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hatte eben auch eine Weile eine FreeNAS im Einsatz hier.
Aber nachdem ich es mir dann im Detail angeguckt habe, war noch ziemlich viel anpoligiert.
Zumindest vor, sagen wir mal, einem Jahr oder so, wo wir uns das angeguckt haben.
Ich mag die ganzen Sachen nicht.
Ich mag beispielsweise auch Open Media World nicht.
Deswegen hatte ich ja lange Zeit einfach ganz simpel mit Debian Server...
Stimmt nicht, damals war es noch Ubuntu Server.
Ubuntu, das war noch die Zeit, wo ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die ich mir heute nicht erklären kann, immer noch gedacht habe,
Ubuntu Server größerer Debian.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Früher habe ich immer Debian benutzt.
Dann habe ich irgendwann Ubuntu Server benutzt.
Und jetzt benutze ich wieder Debian, weil ich überhaupt keinen Grund mehr sehe für Ubuntu Server.
Ich glaube, ich bin damals umgeschwenkt von Debian Server, also von Debian, auf...
Also zu Zeiten von...
Okay, lasst mal überlegen, Leute.
Kriegen wir...
Wie viele Debian Versionen kriegen wir aus dem Kopf hin, Leute?
Lasst mal überlegen.
Woody?
Sarge?
Woody, Sid ist immer Testing.
Bookworm ist das Neueste.
Edge?
Edge auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall Edge.
Oh, fuck.
Warte mal.
Ich muss mal in mich gehen.
Wie hieß der?
Bullseye?
Gab es noch Bullseye?
Buster.
Buster ist der Hund, gell?
Moment, wie heißt der?
T-Rex aus...
Toy Story?
Der heißt einfach nur Rex.
Rex gab es noch nie.
Warum gab es kein Debian?
Warum gab es nie Debian Rex, Mann?
Ach doch, gab es, gab es.
Oh.
Debian Release 1997.
Fuck, Alter.
Hier ist Rex.
Okay, okay, lasst mal in uns gehen.
Also, was haben wir?
Woody, Sarge, Edge.
Jesse?
Buster, Bullseye, Bookworm.
Bookworm.
Mehr fallen wir nicht ein.
Sonst noch jemand?
Ohne, ohne zu googeln.
Ja?
Ohne zu googeln.
Och nee.
Nein.
Hier ist überhaupt nix F.
Hier ist nix F.
Ihr, ihr, ihr, ihr jebaitet mich.
Ich hab noch nicht mal einen Frame.
Oh, doch.
Ich, ich hab, oh, guck mal, ich hab keine...
Lenny?
Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Kann sich irgendjemand an Debian Lenny erinnern?
Ja.
Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Das ist, das ist...
Nee, hier ist nix F.
Ihr habt die Aufzählung nicht mitbekommen.
Also, an die Debian Version, an die ich mich erinnern kann.
Äh.
Bookworm.
Bullseye, Buster.
Jesse.
Edge.
Woody.
Tomato?
Sagt mir nix.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, Potato.
Weil ne Tomate, ne Tomate aus Toy Story fällt mir nicht ein.
Das muss wenn schon Potato gewesen sein, nicht Tomato.
Sarge.
Sarge gab's auch, genau.
Sarge war, glaub ich, das aller, allererste Debian, was ich verwendet...
Ja, hab ich, hab ich, leider.
Zertge.
Das andere gibt's nicht.
Wart mal, Debian Version...
Äh, History?
Ja, aus irgendwelchen Gründen hab ich damals gedacht,
äh, ich benutze...
Wahrscheinlich bin ich von Debian auf Ubuntu umgeschwenkt, weil die Packages ne Weile immer aktueller waren.
So in Zeiten, wo gefühlt alle Schaltjahre mal ein neues Debian rausgekommen ist.
Wobei, wenn man sich anguckt, im Prinzip ist das, ist die Release Schedule immer gleich, ja?
Gibt's so alle, alle zwei Jahre gibt's ein neues Debian.
Okay, also.
Das erste war Buzz.
Ja gut.
Das bietet sich auch, das bietet sich auch irgendwie an.
Ist ja eines mit der bekanntesten Charakter aus Toy Story.
Ich würd mal sagen, Woody und Buzz.
Die, vom, vom ersten Toy Story an.
Rex?
Genau, da hätt ich auch mit gerechnet, dass der da...
Bo, ich hab keine Ahnung, wer Bo aus Toy Story ist.
Ach, Bo ist diese komische Puppe da, okay, ja, ja, ja.
Sich, ist das nicht die Freundin von Woody?
Toy Story Lore?
Keckel?
Ham?
Weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Slink?
Keiner.
Potato gab's?
Potato?
Woody, Sarge, Edge, Lenny.
Lenny?
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht an Debian Lenny...
Leute.
Erinnert sich irgendjemand, das ist doch Fake News, oder?
Das, erinnert sich irgendjemand an Debian Lenny?
Vielleicht war das die Zeit, wo ich kein Debian mehr benutzt hab.
Okay, 2009, ey.
Wer, wer ist Lenny aus Toy Story?
Das zum...
Leute, ich hab noch nicht mal ne Ahnung, in welchem Toy Story das Ding überhaupt vorgekommen ist.
Also Lenny sagt mir gar nix.
Squeeze?
Wheezy?
Jessie?
Stretch?
Was bedeutet Orange?
Still main...
Okay, Buster.
Ja, gut, Buster ist ja noch nicht so alt, ja.
Buster?
Bullseye, Bookworm, Trixie Forky.
Und Sid, Sid ist immer...
Sid ist immer, also quasi immer die, die Testing.
Die heißt, die hieß schon immer Sid.
Sid ist die, ist der Nachbarjunge, glaube, ne?
Debian 10.
Jetzt haben wir uns, jetzt haben wir uns super lang mit irgendwelchen...
Oh, da ist er.
Da ist er.
Aber wir haben uns immer und super lang mit irgendwelchen Debian Versionen auseinandergesetzt
und hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich...
Wie bin ist jetzt überhaupt drauf gekommen?
Ubuntu.
Irgendwas, ja.
Ja, es auch.
Ich benutze es auch nicht mehr.
Michael-5!
Dich habe ich ja voll übersehen!
Michael-5 Spillian ist auch wieder am Start!
Bist noch da?
Schön, dass du auch mal wieder hier bist!
Pog!
Ganz übersehen!
Ich hoffe du bist noch da!
In letzter Zeit.
Ey Windows 20.
Habe ich noch an.
increasingly.
극 Sie сокodago?
Echt jetzt ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht du bist du bist einfach gar nicht mehr so oft da
Ich bin gerade überlegen mein notebook das windows 11 nicht supportet auf linux umzustellen aber ich habe
Also ich finde ich finde wenn man
Noch noch recht neu ist was linux angeht dann kann man mit linux mit eigentlich gar nicht so viel falsch machen
Ansonsten ganz ehrlich
Also meine erste db an versionen war glaube ich sah
Wo die habe ich tatsächlich nicht mitgekriegt also meine erste db an version was
2000 aber nicht 2005 ich hab ich hab's benutzt
Als es noch ganz knapp testing war
also so irgendwie 2006 oder sowas
und
Kann ich mich heute noch
daran erinnern die hatten noch kein xorg die hatten noch den xorg vorgänger
Sowas gab es tatsächlich auch mal ja heute ist ja xorg schon outdated overrated jebaited
Die ich weiß gar nicht x3 86 genau ja das war es genau genau
Mir wäre der name wirklich nicht mehr eingefallen und bei edge war es dann xorg um mich zu jebaiten im stream
Oder machst du das wirklich?
Ich habe mal eine frage ich kenne mich in linux nur wenig mit netzwerk
config und allgemeinen commands beziehungsweise standardpaketen aus alles in non desktop version ja
Das da lernt man es auch am besten
Möchte jetzt etwas mehr in linux einstellen mit absolut überformen mit desktop gibt es ein gibt es da gute startpunkte also ganz ehrlich
Ich mag keinen es ist meine persönliche meinung ja ich mag keinen der normalen linux desktops
aber zum einstieg würde ich sagen ist linux mit
cinnamon wahrscheinlich ganz gut
Das ist das was die leute noch immer empfehlen du kannst dir das ja mal angucken ob das was für dich ist
was mir persönlich am liebsten gefällt ist das hier nämlich gar kein richtiger desktop sondern einfach
Ja also desktop gibt es hier gar nicht ich habe keine icons und nix hier kannst du auch nicht klicken und keine icons hin machen
ich habe im prinzip nur drei desktops mit
fenster im fullscreen
der scheiß genommen
Ich habe im prinzip hier nur drei desktops die ich durchschalten kann mit hotkey
und ein neuestes hintergrundbild
Und das war's was ich kann theoretisch bis
bis neun desktops durchschalten aber ich habe meistens nur die ersten drei im einsatz und das war's ich habe prinzipiell nur fenster im
in der regel meistens nur fenster im fullscreen
meistens nur fenster im fullscreen sieht dann so aus oder so aus oder so oder so oder wie auch immer
und
das wichtigste habe ich auch am start
ask aquarium
Aber das ist für den einstieg also ja doch weil ich kann theoretisch
man kann sagen ich kann theoretisch auch ja fenster haben die sich wie fenster verhalten aber keine fensterrahmen und nix aber